In 2018,
Vladimir Putin personally inaugurated this bridge to Crimea and even drove a truck across what was
billed as a major infrastructure upgrade for the occupied peninsula.
Now,
satellite images show the extent of the damage on the bridge,
The only link between Crimea and Russian land partially collapsed after a major
explosion,
which set a train on fire and killed several people.
There's a bridge that was a symbol of Russian power,
so inflicting such serious damage.
Clearly a sticking by the Ukrainian as a morale boost.
Very little is known about the blast,
but security footage and verified social media clips offer clues that can help us understand what
happened there.
Let's take a look at videos taken just before the explosion,
Russia said it was investigating the role of a truck in the security footage verified by the
news agency story,
fel a truck appears to explode close to the epicenter of the blast.
However,
engineering and defense experts say that the vehicle is unlikely to have been the primary cause of the
incident.
That case will be a hole in the middle of the bridge and not just the collapse of two
spans.
They think that the exposure most likely came from under the bridge decks,
there are various theories.
It could be a manned or unmanned boat or it could be commanded divers placing
shaped charges on pillars of the bridge and in this video,
just as that truck drives by,
you can see something that resembles the nose of the ship appearing under the bridge just an instant
before the detonation,
The fact that the surface of the road appears to be unscathed in aftermath.
Images also suggests that the attack could have come from underneath.
According to military analysts and engineers.
The damage done to the bridge can also help estimate the amount of explosives used in the attack.
Demolition experts we've spoken with say that uh if this was not
professionally by placing shaped charges at the support structures of the bridge,
it would require a huge amount of explosive,
several sort of trash can sized explosive charges.
So who's behind the blast?
Russia blamed Ukraine,
00:02:05.370 --> aN:aN:000NaN
a
Ukrainian presidential adviser respond to Putin on twitter calling his accusations too
cynical.
Ukrainian officials welcomed the attack on social media but didn't claim responsibility,
experts agree that if keith managed to pull off this operation,
it shows a dramatic increase in its ability to counter Russia's invasion.
This bridge was one of the most highly protected structures in the world.
This is an attack that is hundreds of miles from the Ukrainian lines.
So it would have required deep infiltration into Russian territory
and very high level of secrecy.
The bridge is a strategic artery for the supply of fuel,
military equipment and food to Russian troops fighting to hold ground in southern Ukraine.
Russia said traffic on the bridge was partially restored quickly after the blast and ferry links were
resuming still many civilians were left stranded and images showed long lines of
cars trying to leave Crimea.
The Kremlin had warned of severe consequences.
Should keep try to strike this infrastructure.
It is an escalation,
but again,
it's not the first time that Ukraine has struck,
either in Crimea or infrastructure targets in Russia.
This significantly reduces the capacity of the Russian forces that are fighting in south Ukraine and
trying to fend off the Ukrainian offensive.
Two days after the bridge attack,
Russian strikes hit at the heart of Kiev,
as well as other Ukrainian cities in Moscow's biggest missile barrage in the country in
months.